what is their
answer to climate change because sure i
could say all that stuff but dave could
you really think this whole thing is a
farce could you really think that a
bunch of people who lie about everything
they wouldn't lie about this this is
serious stuff i mean sure they lied
about kovid they lie about literally
every public policy thing they call
everyone a racist every single thing
that they do is complete nonsense but
but climate change i mean dave please
what are you doing for god's sakes well
now they're pulling one out of their uh
basic uh simpsons movie situation you
remember the simpsons movie the plot of
the oh no wait that wasn't the simpsons
movie the simpsons movie
i'm crossing up two things it was a
simpsons episode where mr burns blocks
out the sun that was the connor i i'm
blaming you on this one the movie was
about the dome we went through this
before the show the movie was about the
dome okay you all know about the dome
right
but the simpsons five part episode when
maggie who shot mr burns was because mr
burns blocked out the sun right he
blocked out the sun because he wanted to
burn slant drilling right so he could
make all the money uh well if you
thought that was crazy and that i
believe if i'm not mistaken i think i
was in college that was around 1994 mr
burns blocking out the sun well the
world economic forum's looking into it
we've got a tweet from the daily wire
should be no risk world economic forum
pushes space bubbles to block out the
sun
and stop climate change and there's of
course a picture of evil psycho leader
klaus
vader yeah not a good dude okay so they
are literally taking a plot from the
simpsons
from
roughly 30 years ago we are going to
block out the sun who is
what is the world economic forum why do
these people have any power over any of
our governments why do our leaders flock
to them and listen to them and and have
i mean none of it makes any sense
uh and again do you think that whether
it's a shield from the sun or a space
bubble or we put bubbles on the water to
reflect the sun back up so the oceans
stay cool do you think any of this works
none of it works it's all made up this
is the grift of griffs this is the
you know what the sun do you guys know
about the sun so the sun is this hot
ball
okay it's a star and you maybe when you
were a kid you looked up at the stars
right you might have wished upon a star
okay and there's a lot of stars carl
sagan uh famous astronomer uh and uh was
he a physicist also he was an astronomer
at least he did cosmos of course and
wrote the movie contact one of my
favorite movies he used to talk about
billions and billions of stars right
that was uh before memes he used to go
on johnny carson billions and billions
and uh the stars that are out there
there's many of them and actually our
sun which is a star is not that special
it's just that our earth our planet that
we're on happens to be close enough to
it all the conditions are right so that
life was able to start here
we now have a
conglomerate globalist group that would
like to block us from that thing that
thing that people have prayed to that
thing that creates light and life and
all of that stuff
that's what these freaks are interested
in i'm not a big fan of getting rid of
the sun okay just want to be rec uh very
very clear about that but there's more
there's more it's not just that they
want to get rid of the sun
here is alibaba group president j
michael evans at the world economic
forum talking about how once they get
rid of the sun they have other plans for
you
we're developing
through technology an ability for
consumers to measure their own carbon
footprint
what does that mean that's
where are they traveling how are they
traveling what are they eating what are
they consuming on the platform
so individual carbon footprint tracker
stay tuned we don't have it operational
yet but this is something that we're
working on
i mean that is some death star level
[ __ ]
this thing's not fully operational but
we're gonna make it fully operational
but as you guys know there's always a
way to blow up a death star and that's
what i'm here to do michael liked that
one um what what did you hear what he
said who what when where we're going to
track you where you are who you are when
you are all of those things at your
carbon footprint and what you're doing
online
what is going on here people i just am
not interested in this i'm not
interested in this and i i guess i have
to destroy these people
i have nothing better to do i really
don't i have a lot going on i do have a
lot going on i have a busy day you guys
see my calendar i have a lot going on
every day even today i have to go to the
physical therapist it's not that i have
nothing to do i just feel that i have to
save the world
just in me
annoying as hell sometimes i gotta tell
you